[Musique]
le milliardaire jeff bezos a gagné son
pari
après un décollage réussi au texas sa
fusée complètement automatisée donc sans
pilote l'a transporté avec trois autres
passagers aux frontières de l'espace
en tout le voleur a duré à peine 11
minutes mais l'homme le plus riche du
monde a visiblement apprécié son
expérience et ses succès de celui de
goodrich brendan healy à dijon annonce
la naissance d'une nouvelle industrie le
tourisme spatial
aujourd'hui les simples mortels peuvent
espérer mettre le pied dans la cour des
grands à 100 km d'altitude
c'est ce qu'on appelle un voile
balistique n'est ce pas vous montez au
et ensuite la gravité fait son travail
et elle vaut ramène au sol donc si on
atteint l'espace mais on ne vole pas
dans l'espace d'après on ne fait pas le
tour de la terre c'est l'arrivée à
maturité de plusieurs technologies dont
celle du pilotage automatique qui rendu
cet exploit possible au fur et à mesure
des années d expérience d'un dans les
fusées mais dans les avions et même dans
les voitures on commence à maîtriser ses
technologies et on fait de plus en plus
confiance aux prises de décisions
automatisée des ordinateurs jeff bezos
ce n'a pas encore annoncé le coup de
billets sur les ailes de sa compagnie
mais vu jean les proposent à 250 mille
dollars pièce alors que spacek ce exige
50 millions de dollars pour chaque vol
orbital d'une astronaute de la nasa
on ignore également les conséquences sur
l'atmosphère terrestre de la
multiplication anticipé des vols de
fusées
si on parle de centaines voire de
milliers de vols annuellement et même
peut-être plus on va peut-être faire
face à un problème environnemental est
aussi un problème d'acceptabilité
sociale le même problème s'est posé avec
l'industrie aéronautique dans le passé
et les efforts de recherche permettent
maintenant par diminuer les impacts
c'est des études qui vont prendre du
temps mais je pense pas que l'industrie
va exploser du jour ou non mais ça va
prendre encore des années avant qu'elle
devienne mature et les sciences fiction
là pour l'accompagner
ici norma grondin radio canada montréal